we've seen the personal subject pronouns
in romance those pronouns point out
who's performing in action as in Engel
cantle which can be said contour without
the pono
vulgar latin and Romance languages also
use pronouns for a person impacted by
the action much like English me in sees
me
these are object pronouns with verbs
these typically sit immediately to the
left of the verb in romance be this you
see maybe this you see me when an action
impacts somebody directly a Latin
accusative pronoun like a man or thing
is placed before the verb mevy that
Davee dead
the first and second person plural
objects are nose and voz third person
objects come from the accusative of
Allah and Allah Allah Vedas
Alavi this in las vidas
plural them derives from the nominative
Allah and Allah in eastern romance
Italian libido libido
verbs that impact their object
indirectly like to me in says to me have
an indirect object pronoun to the left
in modern romance these are mostly
identical to the direct object pronouns
madatha emoji Medici and so on the
difference does become apparent in the
third person
where dative forms are used instead
dative case Ely to him or to her Elodie
Co or dative Elise to them
Elise Tico vulgar latin actually used
the dative forms and other persons for
indirect objects a difference that still
survives in romanian method it movida
with a direct object
medikit mzj with an indirect object
when a verb can take both direct and
indirect object pronouns they both still
fall to the left of the verb the gate
says me diecut says to me
Lu diecut says it Malouda gate says it
to me
or that gives T that gives you the loss
that gives them till loss that gives
them to you
these object pronouns often trail
non-finite forms particularly
infinitives Decatur tillu to say it to
you
Spanish the Tipton's Oh Italian dear
Taylor
no but notice that French and Romanian
keep them on the left
when a verb has the same subject and
object
it's called reflexive reflexive objects
in English have an ending self like I
see myself Romance languages used the
same pronouns you've learned as
reflexive movido
vivy this this is considered reflexive
the exception is again
in the third person where say means
herself himself itself or themselves
Alisa V date
Seve dent
so much for object pronouns with verbs
prepositions small particles that relate
time or space like under or to or beside
are followed by a different set of
pronouns
these are stressed and mostly resemble
the subject pronouns add notes to us a
Delilah
to her but me and you are different a me
Amy Amy M WA la mina or Adeeb Adeeb a TA
at wa Bettina romance personal pronouns
can be objects of verbs and of
prepositions now you have a taste of how
they do they